sí
hasta ahora hemos visto la colocación y
el ajuste de tamaño que se realizan con
la traslación y el cambio de escalas
pero los animadores necesitan esa toma
ya y están empezando a pasearse por tu
oficina y checar cómo vas en el montaje
de una toma también necesitamos orientar
a los objetos además de colocarlos en el
lugar y del tamaño adecuados orientar a
un objeto generalmente consiste en una o
más rotaciones
así es que regresemos a nuestra toma
para colocar a volpi vamos a necesitar
las tres operaciones voy a empezar
cambiando su escala para hacerla del
tamaño adecuado después voy a usar la
rotación para orientar la de acuerdo a
lo que indica el boceto y finalmente la
colocaré en su lugar
usando la traslación ya vimos que
existen fórmulas muy sencillas para las
operaciones de traslación y cambio de
escala que sólo involucran la
multiplicación y la suma pero las
fórmulas de rotación son un poco más
complicadas e involucran conceptos de
trigonometría todo
no te preocupes por esos detalles los
vamos a ver más adelante por ahora
quiero hablar acerca de la razón por la
que escogí las operaciones en ese orden
cambio de escala rotación y luego
traslación
supongamos que empiezo con la traslación
y luego la rotación
y finalmente el cambio de escala
volpi termina en el lugar equivocado así
es que el orden puede importar muchísimo
y recuerdas como le decimos cuando el
orden si importa
cierto no conmuta tividad
tomando en cuenta la no conmutativa edad
usa las tres operaciones para terminar
tu interpretación del cuarto de andy
cuando termines el director aprobará tu
trabajo
y después de eso puedes diseñar todas
las tomas que quieras
podrías crear algunas otras opciones que
no nos pidieron ni el departamento de
arte ni el director para hacer una gran
película lo mejor es explorar muchas
opciones y seleccionar la mejor de ellas
diviértete mucho